hello my children oh one of the
questions I get asked surprisingly often
is that sometimes people come up to me
and they'll say hey in the top eleven
honest anime women you know do really
the link is up there that's why your
favorites in the blah blah blah what
people have done are stand when I do the
nostalgia critic especially now that I'm
coming back is that nostalgia Craig yeah
he's a character and yeah there's a lot
of my opinion in there but a lot of
times especially for the top eleven list
uh I try to get sort of the mass opinion
for the most part which I'm not always
good at you know it's sort of a mix of
mass opinion and my opinion essentially
uh but with that said a lot of people
keep coming up to me they keep talking
about the top eleven like hottest anime
women and stuff and they're just like oh
that's mine - it's mine - and the truth
is a lot of those aren't my I was serve
going for you know like the mass opinion
they're uh like I won't even put Jessica
Rabbit up there
honestly I she can't exist I don't know
that she looks a little too weird to me
um so I thought maybe be kind of cool if
anything just to show the difference
between nostalgia critic and myself uh
what my favorite top 11 hottest animated
women are and at first I'm sorry like
even when I start the list out saying
yeah this is a little odd um because
these women are not real and they don't
exist but at the same time I think
there's something to be said about
fiction and what we value is beauty what
we want to see created and representing
Beauty whether it be the visual or the
spiritual the emotional all that stuff
uh so I thought just be fun to talk
about um so that's pretty much what this
list is right now I'm gonna tell you
Doug's top 10 hottest anime women in my
opinion
number ten jamika from babies kids now I
know it's hard to say anything that good
came out of this movie and to be fair
she's not like a very complex character
she's just sort of generally nice and
has a nice design but uh when that said
she's generally nice and has a nice
design I don't know why this there's
just something about the way this
character looks and the way she's drawn
and there's just sort of this kindness
to her in this very angry rebellious
world that they created in this movie
but at the same time I think they sort
of made it that she isn't just I mean
she's a totally bland I mean she does
you know have her limits and you will
get angry so it's not like she's just
the big QDI
nothing up here I thought she was pretty
likable but I will say again it's mostly
the design I think they just designed
this woman to make her so brainy I think
she's such a very nice looking design
and I wish I could say more about her
but this this is sort of one of the more
selfish ones where it just sort of comes
down to the design and that she's
generally just sort of likable um so
that one my more complex ones but she's
a
number nine
a Hughes from the Iron Giant this was
the mother in the Iron Giant and Brad
Bird just designs these great-looking
women I'll tell you what I mean by that
it's that they're not like traditional
knockouts they're not like women you'd
see like in oh yeah I want that they're
just very traditional nice pretty women
and they just look so they have very
kind faces and very expressive eyes but
he still gives them character too and
that's very much what I saw with this
character is that she was very much
she's this working mother and she gets
exhausted she gets tired but she's still
trying to best to be a mother and you
know she can't do her best but you know
and she can't be home a lot of times
with the kid and that that's really
tough a lot of times to be like yeah but
is something about the way they made her
character you see that she's really
putting the effort in and that her and
the son do have this do it this very
strong connection I think actually he
probably is at that age where he can and
he can be home alone you know fine
another big part that honestly is
Jennifer Aniston's voice and jefra has
to as one of those actresses I think is
Kylie can Hathaway where a lot of people
serve put their nose up in her and they
say oh she's some shit so you know she
can't be good I think she's very good
I agree she's in shit lots of shit but
any time she's in it she's always good
and I didn't grow up with friends every
time I saw the show I thought it was
terrible but maybe she was good in it I
don't know I'm only going on her as an
actress and every time I seen her as an
actress I've always been impressed with
what she's done I think she has a talent
of taking parts that could very easily
just sort of be token nice woman part
you know and nothing much else and she
brings something to it and I think again
this was a perfect example of and I
think she's very likable she has some
she has some funny moments without them
being forced I really don't like those
scenes and family movies or romantic
films or whatever where it's like there
with the kid but they're really forced
like oh yeah we're on the same level you
and me it's like no it's parent and kid
and they establish that and they
establish that you know even though she
can't always be there when she is there
she's very good at what she does um so I
that character a lot I think it's a
really great design I think it's a very
kind character it's a very smart
character so that's number nine number
eight
April O'Neil I am so sorry I'm so sorry
to have this choice on there because I
mean I especially I'm so anti you know
serve damsel distressed of Cosette's so
much of what she was the Turtles always
had to go save her every other episode
they had to save April she kept getting
into trouble and I don't know to me this
was the person you wanted to save you
know she was very she was very energized
she was very passionate she was very
funny uh it was a very different kind of
design I still not sure how that
hairstyle work serve anyone can really
duplicated it's very it's kind of very
messy but still has like this nice shape
but it's hard to define the shit I don't
draw so I I obsess over designs um the
jumpsuit makes no sense because I've
talked about before but she does look
good in it even though she does
constantly get into trouble it's kind of
justified in a sense in the way that
Lois Lane is not they're both reporters
but something about April seems almost
enjoyably psychotic like she adores her
job she's essentially a workaholic it
james rolfe footed Bessey's that she
just loves her job and there's such
appreciation for how much she loves her
job I don't know I think there's just
something really cool about that I think
she is just so upbeat that even when
she's in trouble she's still sort of
cracking jokes but not in a way that's
like yeah yeah come on save me we've
done this like a million times like
she's still thankful she's still
grateful and I don't know what it is
about her there's just something
surprisingly likeable about this
character that I really should hate but
I I don't know what it is it is from the
NC uh top eleven list that's what I
still stand by it's sort of hard to
explain why but I don't know I I think
she's fun
number seven
Harley Quinn this is another one from
the top 11 list and GAD do I even have
to go into great detail I guess it's a
little bizarre when you take into
account that you can't see a lot of her
I mean you got the skin tight body of it
obviously but with the face you know a
lot of its in makeup you can't really
see the hair but I think a lot of it
does come from the fact that she does
have this incredibly fun / tragic
personality to her and I think it's such
a cool idea to give the Joker
a sidekick and that they actually pulled
it off because actually that sort of
sounds insane that the Joker's one of
the greatest villains of all time to
start like giving Darth Vader a sidekick
or something it's like no which it's got
Vader he doesn't need a sidekick but
Harley was great Harley you had so much
energy and again there's just this love
for what she does and she's crazy and
she's funny and she's energized and
every second she's on screen even when
the Joker's on screen you're looking at
her and you like how much she's
constantly going along with the joke and
how much for the most part she's on the
same level as the Joker with the
exception of the fact that he is
obviously taking advantage of her he is
just using her as a means to an end
um and people you know read so much into
that relationship about whether or not
they've done it or have they not done it
they probably have um there are several
times where they indicate they have but
who knows I I wasn't there well I'm so
glad that character took off so far from
was essentially a kids show
you know kids show a Batman and how that
show has just defined so much and it's
changed so much with Batman in general
in the Batman lore and all this all
these great things I'm just always blown
away by how just one impact that show
had um you know something that was
apparently for kids so uh I love that
element when people can take something
so seriously and get it done right even
with their side characters that was just
supposed to be a side character and turn
into just a really great wonderful
character so props
number six
Damona from gargoyles I don't know if
I'm saying her name right Marina Sirtis
I think she does the voice for this
character she was from Star Trek next
generation she was a Troy and I won't
say a lot of it does come from that
voice there's a very distinct strong
voice uh but at the same time this is a
very well-put-together
character who again has this great
strength but also this great tragedy has
this unbelievable backstory I think they
had to take like some like eight
episodes to explain her backstory
because it just spread out over years um
and a lot of you might be thinking out
so you're into like what reptile
gargoyle is whatever and stuff like that
no fuck that shit that is just a pretty
woman with pointy ears it's a Vulcan
essentially and they just painted her
blue that's it I don't know she's
supposed to be scaly or whatever but
they don't animate her that way so it's
it's fine you know what she turns human
I remember in the show there's actually
something happens where she can actually
turn human half the time so I'm just
like okay that that's old me um but it's
just a great I just remember being so
fascinated by that character and it was
a great turmoil going back and forth
between who she was fighting for was she
fighting for herself was she fighting
for her love was she fighting for a
cause and and what was her even her
focus anymore even her focus of revenge
serve God mumble and stuff it's just
very complex and I'm very much a
Shakespearean character in my opinion
it's like a Shakespearean villain and
God was a lot of time I forget to
include on stuff and I don't know why
because it had a lot Bela that they're
really strong it was a very very strong
character it's a great design a lot of
people probably wondering why I didn't
put what the cop Lisa I think I'm there
she's a good character and everything
but she's a little little too safe a
little too I don't want to say bland but
it's her like you know she's always
going to do the right thing and I can
get boring um so
Damona was the one that I always thought
was just really great to look at and
really great to listen to I said that
voice is unbelievable just a great
strong character and
a really enjoy her so yeah not to
gargoyles yet but maybe she'll be the
Gateway
number five
Alice Tompkins kind of figures I'd have
a character from a show called The
Critic oh when the critic went off the
air and came back for its second run on
a different channel they changed it up
again they redesigned things a little
bit one of the things they did was that
they gave Jay essentially a girlfriend
is she looks like a person she wasn't
funny necessarily like the other
character she was sort of the moral
support which again I usually find
boring but maybe it could just be the
southern accent I don't know the
southern accent seems to really add a
lot but she's a little bit more
knowledgeable or that she doesn't take
crap or whatever but outside of that I
think it's the fact that she did have a
kid as well she did work with Jay and a
lot of things Jay Sherman the the main
character um and again it's just this
wonderful great design I've actually
taken a lot of the designs from the
critic and worked into my own work in
terms of drawings it's a very kind
design I would just look at this woman
and you would just say that that's a
kind woman
and she was and she could definitely get
some funny lines in there in the review
must go on I stole this delivery from
her there's a scene where I think Jay
his stomach would talk sometimes it
sounds really odd but he swears his
stomach would talk at one point like the
stomach says Phoebe or something's like
patience my pet and she just goes Jay
honey who are you talking to like she
said so like she's really concerned and
I totally stole that for what I'm
talking to Lewis and he apparently
here's his uh his characters talking so
uh yeah it's a character so good I have
to steal from her I don't know what else
to say there's just a really nice sort
of southern comfort to her so I
definitely enjoyed her a lot
number four
Tiye from The Princess and the Frog yeah
I know that's kind of odd cuz that's
more of a recent movie it's kind of like
Glee you're still looking the cartoon
characters it I'm sorry it's a really
pretty design it's a really nice
character there's just something about
the way they design her again another
workaholic I don't know what it is I
think we're coholic sir sexy it's really
odd um I just it's like I go do shit I
just like women who do shit and she's
just someone like she worked like three
or four jobs and then she's working
towards her goal even when she's a frog
she's like fuck that shit I'm gonna keep
going out care from a frog again just
coming back to the design I really like
again the very big expressive disney
eyes and you know there was at one point
they tried to you can probably see this
where they're trying to say oh they're
trying to whiten up the black person you
know with tiana take a look we're gonna
turn her skin white and you're gonna see
she looks just like any other white
disney princess bullshit when you do
that that does not look like a Caucasian
person okay that looks like at the very
least it looks like a mix they're just
drawn to well you know you just look at
that face and you say if you had to
guess I'm taking out the skin Kelly say
oh that's probably African American and
it is and it's beautiful the way they
desire just looks unbelievable and I was
convinced of that through most of the
movie had to see her as a frog I'm like
no that's a great design but has her
flaws too you know I like the fact that
the workaholic aspect was actually a
flaw but like you know something good
but it was also a flaw that you know she
wouldn't give herself a break and I
think that's pretty cool I think that's
actually that's something you don't
usually see in the kids film you know
cuz there aren't too many kids that are
workaholics but um there are other
lessons in there too anyway so uh Tiana
I I think she's great
every
this is par from The Incredibles again
this is another Brad Bird design I'm
actually sort of shocked I don't have
more 3d women on this list maybe they
haven't see enough I don't know but just
another really nice design something you
could tell was drawn first and then
turned into a 3d model which I think
it's great I think it's a lot more
expression in something you draw which
is then made 3d um and you see you're in
two great outfit so you see or is the
the housewife you know it's just the
everyday shirt you know everyday outfit
you know still looks great and yes here
is the superhero and again she looks
great ability to stretch I think is very
clever I think her personality is a lot
of fun um and that it's definitely a
take note on sense it's you know going
out there but she's very she's very
playful - I like she'll definitely in
the first bit before they get married
the way she sort of plays with mr.
incredible and they go back and forth
with you know sort of like gender roles
and stuff like that I'm not sure how I
feel about the fact that they sort of
made her totally okay than now she's a
housewife because on the one hand I
think that's really cool I think that
you know she sort of gave birth to these
kids and it's like okay she now has a
new life you know that get to these kids
and mr. Parr is the one that has his
midlife crisis and everything so on the
one hand that's pretty cool on the other
hand she was a superhero and you sort of
think well wouldn't she kind of miss
that - one that eventually saw her catch
up with her cuz she seems to have like
no problem with it at all so I'm very
I'm very mixed on that but I think I
think I like it more because it shows
that she is adaptable or flexible she
like to say in the movie there's
something cool about the fact that she
will just accept what's given to her and
that you know she got three kids out of
it you know what that's pretty cool and
that she can live you know a good life
would that be totally content so that's
that's cool character right there
aren't you
rogue from x-men again with the
southerners I'm just realizing this as
you are like I put a lot of southerners
on it some about the accent or the
person that I don't know and it's I
can't even know where they British
people I'm here like the British accent
I think it's like the most attractive X
and I am no British women so very odd
they're all southerners but again I
digress
rogue she was also on the NCS top 11
oddest women I think I put her lower on
the list I mean okay yeah but the suit
and everything looks good but outside of
that it's just I adore this character
because all this shit aventure isn't our
character just every fucking thing you
can imagine just slams down on her both
figuratively and literally and she just
gets my back up and his smile
aspirational make a joke she'll take
whatever a truck and throw it back in
their face uh she has this incredible
backstory that's just so heartbreaking
and I think when you see someone come
out of them they're just so optimistic
and they just want to keep going and
they they don't want make it anyone
else's problem it's sort of their deal
and they'll you know they'll live with
it
LFL upbeat she is and I love how
enthusiastic she is I love how strong
she is and she shows it off you know
she's a bit of a show-off too and it's
when I think of Rome being really great
like they had her great in the comics
the cartoon I - I would say that's the
one I think of the most maybe because
they had the boys in there - in such a
pitch-perfect voice and I think that
really does add a lot because you can
you can read the comics and the comics
you know do it great I mean they have
all the turmoil they have all our
optimism - but there is something about
hearing that voice and the inflections
that this voice has and it's a very well
chosen voice and whatever does is just
great actress it's just a really good
strong beautiful character you know I
don't know why she would wear an outfit
like that but at the same time all of
them wear ridiculous outfits that that's
one of the few comics where I'm just
like you can't really shout sexism at
this or anything because every person in
the x-men where skin-tight
ridiculousness and you can't get past it
I mean they're all none of them should
be
able to move they should be and that's
it um so but regardless I love room and
I think it's a great character whatever
her last name is I don't know if they
ever gave her a last name or something
like that I'm so fine but yeah
Rose great
and my number one hottest animated woman
is
Bell now this is really ironic because
in the Nostalgia Craig stop 11:00 I said
Bell didn't qualify because you have
Ariel and Jasmine they showed their
belly buttons again that's that's an
establishing critic analysis me I hello
Bell I got that Disney World from one of
the Disney artists there that they were
they were drawn and I got a conversation
with him and he gave me that bill I
always subscribed it's like a female
Jesus it's just everything that's
perfect everything that's kind
everything that's just when you hear the
word beautiful I just think of that
person I think of the drawing of her I
think of the personality I think of how
collected she is I think how calm she is
I think of how she just does her own
shit it doesn't care what anyone thinks
but she doesn't shove it in her face
she's anyone's face she's not looking
for attention it's just she's got that
great voice beautiful speaking voice and
that beautiful singing voice and I guess
people tell me like she was supposed to
be a teenager in that bullshit that's
she's drawn it sounds like an adult I
take it she's an adult you know it's a
like sailing boat supposed to be 14 to
you bullshit silly move and not be
anywhere on my list my reel I can't
standard umm but yeah and in comparison
to like the other sort of Disney
heroines that that they have you know
like Ariel and Jasmine stuff like that
they all have sort of that gen-x quality
that I just don't get that much into
where Belle seems very much like a
timeless character and a lot of the
Disney characters even though really
well developed ones always seem like a
product of their times where Annabelle
really seems timeless just seems like
the best of humanity is not even like
the best that women can offer is the
best anyone can offer yeah you could
make the argument that maybe she's too
perfect I think I talked about that
Disney cember oh and I can see that I
understand she doesn't have that many
flaws but at the same time you know she
has to look past you know the ugliness
of the beast to see the real beauty and
into I mean that that's a flaw to human
flaw
I don't know and she still at the same
time she's
bland neither she also has her limits
you know guests found will keep you know
trying to come on to her and stuff like
that and she'll consulate trying to
fight him off but in a friendly way you
know I love that all she does is just
open the door he's the one that falls
out and into the mud and everything and
I I think the other thing about her too
is that I think at some point you always
find somebody who looks like one of the
Disney characters like you know they're
all modeled after fee by dubov Ariel and
Bella or Sherri stoner and Sherri stoner
really looks like Ariel hey I can see
anyone that looks like Belle Belle is
just a unique design and there can be
people that look very similar but I
never seen anyone that looks quite like
how they designed her I think they just
got a perfect design I don't know I what
I think Beauty might think beautiful a
baladeva means beauty uh I think of that
character I think it's just a really
wonderful great strong kind character so
um yeah those are my top ten most
attractive animated women
I hope all goes well and I will see you
guys next week with the first Ari
installment of the NC take care